thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of careful boys everybody today we have
this Colleen Lionheart oh wow we also
got Anthony we got JoJo
welcome back guys welcome back
um I thought it'd be interesting because
I know everybody's grown up with a
different version of this but what
exactly is in the guy code
oh well I feel like there's like a test
um don't sleep with your friends girl
and letting them know
current girl previous girl just yeah
okay don't sleep with your friends girl
Izzy in there and Mom you guys just do
stuff that's fine though yeah over the
pan uh here's here's probably right
hopping's okay one of the quickest
number one guy codes is like let's say
one of your homeboys tells you that
they're like [ __ ] around uh-huh and
like even if that chick is like your
homie yeah you you're supposed to not
say [ __ ]
oh right no I know facts
where if you got into a fight and
someone jumped in you have to jump in
even if you're outnumbered that's that
is true that's another thing I remember
just have to jump in yeah you got to do
it there was um so have you ever had Guy
Code conflict with other guy code
like you two groups come together and
then you're like hey that's weird Geico
yeah I think yeah that happens like a
maritime Guy Code huh yeah like like
you're at the actual Waters yeah
Arcadia that's a that's a richer
neighborhood right and I I remember
hanging out with these group of people
they're like they're they run deep
they're like 40 friends a ton of friends
right yeah they're they could go into uh
kinjas at that number basically they're
like the kinjas a lot of people
but not not as cool as you guys but so
so when you go there first compliment
yeah
let's give hugs now so the weird thing
to me was that not only were they all
classmates so they date each other but
they dated each other after so they're
just a little [ __ ] commune passing
around yeah like a private school
they're just swapping people around yeah
to me that's weird guy called yeah I
like part of you but at least in the guy
code it's not about not doing it it's
it's about asking
if it's cool it's the code of conduct
code of conduct yeah not doing it but it
isn't always about getting a yes or no
it's about being able to correctly read
the yes or no because some guys within
the guy code will say it's cool because
they're following Geico to being a good
dude but they really don't want you to
do it there's a vein so you also have to
read between that line yeah it's weird
right what if we're homies right and I'm
dating I'm dating this chick for a long
time and then we break up and then you
to work with this chick
let me look at that
how do you deal with that
answer the question right is there
answer the [ __ ] question
wait so say it again oh you're saying
nothing's wrong okay
okay so now you're you're working with
this chick right yeah and then Joe your
fellow employee starts dating this chick
oh within the work yeah now you guys are
all working together but I'm your homie
um you're gonna [ __ ] block that [ __ ] I
mean dating within the workplace that's
a problem by itself outside of for us
isn't that breaking labor coaches some
places it's okay yeah but we're not
talking about Labor code today come on
man we're talking about Guy Code you
know what I mean when I was in The
Improv Community this happened all the
[ __ ] time oh like you're on a team
with the chick and then like you guys
break up and then the a homie from the
team dates her and then all the other
homies go hang out and stuff and I'm
like yo this is [ __ ]
that's because they're all impov kids
you think they're desperate to get that
one girl see I don't I don't know if
that's just as simple as Guy Code I
think that that's just like bad friends
it has like a variable whereas like I
feel like the guy code variable in there
is more like let's say the uh the new
chicken your old homie wanted to hook up
the guy code would be that guy going to
you and being like hey man I'm catching
feelings for this girl and I just want
to like let you know blah blah I want to
you know talk to you about it yeah
that's the guy code but if they're like
[ __ ] doing it and then they're just
hanging out ditch you that's just bad
friends well what what's your protocol
within the guy code when this happens
because here's the thing we used to call
it Hector selector when you have a
friend that constantly makes claims in
saying hey I like this girl now so can
you guys like chill even though she
doesn't like him he's just like claiming
guys the worst exactly that guy's the
[ __ ] he calls dibs as soon as you get
there and you're like this is [ __ ] up
dude she you have no shots yeah but then
like without without getting uh
reciprocated feeling she's already like
hey uh I call David John Colleen because
you know I like her so she's like
ignoring you the whole night
yeah that's cool you're so cool
that's almost like a abusive guy called
or a misuse of guy is that homie a good
friend everybody hypothetically yeah
everybody gets to [ __ ] up at least once
for sure like you're right that's nice
and then twice is like there's a pattern
so even twice I can't get mad at the
third time I'm like if that person comes
in a third time say that like no no no
no you [ __ ] up already
um because like if you just straight up
sleeps with like an ex or something it
doesn't tell you
no I think the [ __ ] exercise will not
tell me I think the [ __ ] could be as
innocent in Hector selector uh variable
because it's like if he claims and then
nothing happens and that was like a
wasted opportunity for everybody else
then it's like no problem second time he
does again waste opportunities like
that's a bad pattern third time he
claims no you're not allowed to do that
because everybody has that friend that's
just so easily smitten and he's like oh
she's the one she's the one it's like
constantly doing that [ __ ] totally so I
had something like that with with a
friend that wasn't like a close friend
we all just were out and about and he
wanted to hang out with girls so I was
just like the girl I was talking to just
told her bring from some friends or
whatever went to a lounge we hung out
and then the girl that he was kind of
getting into like
she doesn't really she wasn't into him
he was being too thirsty and weird so
she's like oh I think I'm gonna go home
you know and then her friend was like oh
no don't leave and then she's like yeah
I'm done like so she left but she
decided to stay but I wasn't I was just
like I don't know you know we're just
gonna like chill tonight I wasn't really
like thinking about hooking up or
anything and then we're like at the club
now and he's like really on to her
because he's so Smitten by her now
because she's the last one left so then
my friend comes up who's a mutual friend
I I barely know this guy and he goes out
of principle you must now [ __ ] that girl
and I was like wait what the king is
telling you that but I was oblivious at
this time that she was into me because I
was like I had like real low self-esteem
it was just like I wasn't like thinking
about that I was just like let's have a
good time yeah I was in a bad place so I
didn't recognize that she was like
coming on that way so he goes hey I just
been watching this whole night he goes
even though he's my friend and he
introduced you know us as friends like
he's a he's being a piece of [ __ ] and he
goes you out of principle you have to go
home with her so then I did and he was
so mad and he said all night he was
talking mad [ __ ] and then after that I
became close to his friend and we're
like buddies now and we don't even talk
to the other guy like dang you guys just
deleted him yeah man that happens yeah
well have you have you been in a
situation where like you let's say say
you knew a group of guys right and you
had your eye on one of them that was the
one that in your mind was like okay he
he's cool but then a different dude
liked you and they all started
respecting that guy so it kind of
blocked everyone else out has that ever
happened no because
um I don't really hang out with a lot of
large groups is very selective with who
I hang out with save on birthdays what'd
you say you said on birthdays it's
really good save on birthdays okay
that's a huge problem dude's Dojo went
down because all the birthdays
40 presents is a lot how many [ __ ]
birthdays a year think about that and
every single one is like
holy [ __ ] what are we gonna do with
four grand a year on just birthdays
birthday presents that's a lot that's a
lot of presents yeah you spend a [ __ ]
ton on birthdays and weddings and stuff
people that's like multiple birthdays
it's about guy code again
it's happened that I just wasn't aware
of like I went out with a group of
friends and it was a situation like that
what's the protocol then for in your
guys's uh upbringings with Guy Code when
two guys both are interested in the same
girl
how do you settle that you have to fight
you have to work yeah
it depends if you guys are actual
friends or not
it depends on how close you are with
this person because if you're close with
them then you can be just straight up
with them all right and then you'll know
if it was you and Bart in like 2000 I
would know out of the conversation who
wants her more oh it wouldn't be up to
her that's for damn sure
nothing to [ __ ] do with it no you
could actually go sit over there we're
gonna figure this out
we'll come to you with a decision in the
past if I would like real talk if I in
the past if I like if I really cared
about this guy and how they felt yeah
and they were really my friend I yeah
out of the conversation we probably
figure it out but if it's not then it's
every man for himself and we weren't
friends in the first place oh this is
when I this is the moment I'll know
because that's like oh is that how you
are okay well who whoever gets her then
we Glenn and we don't have to be friends
yeah I don't know relationships do you
think are ruined because of a mutual
interest in a woman
relationships that should have been
ruined
it's exposing the Achilles heel of that
relationship I think I like the test
it's a nice uh yeah it gets there quick
I think I've only maybe uh maybe ran
into some essence of that and things
like high school but you know you're
like still finding yourself too so I
feel like those relationships are just
you're such an adolescent you're
developing things you know what I mean
you're finding out
um the focus is building a new
relationship already you know versus
even like maintaining an old one so it's
kind of like I feel like
uh two dudes have a mutual interest in a
chick and they can't figure out like Joe
said and stay friends like they're
they're not meant to be friends because
a chick who splits dudes up is that's
how's that how's that a good friendship
between you guys you know that's true
like women don't have that power really
it's it's really just a weakness of the
dudes yeah I just had a flashback of our
mutual friend Eddie yeah so we had a um
uh we would do these Church camp
meetings during the summer it's kind of
like you know where you go with your age
group and then you do capping activities
you stay together it's co-ed and all
that right and that's when you had like
sleepovers co-ed in the same tent
whatever
and then I remember who has a church
co-ed sleepovers in the same tent that's
so awesome yeah well like girls and guys
in one ten several tents several tents
oh in the same like Campground in the
area and then like we would pull
all-nighters and then don't be like
sometimes the the chaperones will come
check in real quick prime time but it
wasn't like we're [ __ ] or nothing but
we were we were I was hoping we were
brushing our privates closely it sounds
like they're dusting for fossils but
they're rushing so so the closest thing
which was pretty extreme back in the day
was putting your arm over someone oh
crazy remember that [ __ ] like my heart's
beating like [ __ ] non-stop that was
crazy right so the juice is Flowing we
both were kind of into the same two-ish
girls but we didn't know and we were
just flirting right and then so like
two-ish
what's wrong with it do you have three
arms she's just legs
we both
there were two pretty girls and you got
you had to just kind of shoot your shot
and see which ones would would like you
back right they had a friend that just
lingered yeah yeah yeah yeah but it was
me and him always for some reason it was
always the same girl at the same time so
it's like there's two of them but then
how come you're giving her attention
when I'm trying to flirt with her and
then so every single time it was a
competition
at the same like it was like why can't
you do this elsewhere right so I
remember like it was always like so
let's say we're in a on a church bus
like going to one of the [ __ ] events
right it's like we're fighting over who
sits next to which girl or whatever and
then once we get there it's like oh she
fell asleep on my shoulder yeah and then
the other one's sitting in the back like
steaming like you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
she has her [ __ ] head on your
shoulder oh those are fun you guys are
gonna get married yeah pretty much and
they're already having babies and then
you go oh she doesn't like me anymore
and then she comes up to you when you're
like in a circle [ __ ] talking ghost
stories or something and she sits next
to you and does this [ __ ] to your arm
and I'm like oh yeah you see that Eddie
you son of a [ __ ] she likes me now and
it would be like that but it would so
severe and then the other girl that we
both kind of like too would be left out
and it would be switching with the four
of us so she must be thinking too like
confused hey we just keep flirting with
the same two girls who can't make a
decision in the meantime the youth
pastor's like guys focus on the Lord
but I think we were like 13 at the time
and we never talked about it yeah it's
all unspoken ever yeah that they're
rubbing privates yeah they're tent but
but the tense walls are like this thick
so you can hear sleeping bags
you can hear everything oh that reminds
me I had um so I have I have a homie
that uh he's really good on diet code
and he I remember he got really pissed
I'll tell you who this is afterwards but
he got really mad about Mike song one
time and he was like man my song
every time my girl is around he just
becomes this comedian and starts making
her laugh so damn hard
and he was like he was like is Mike's
song this funny all the time like or is
it just when my girl's here
and he was like steaming bad [ __ ] yeah
Mike I was like oh no man maybe it's
just the question is Mike song a
comedian all the time absolutely not but
he's a player
you guys know you guys know who Jets
quarterback Zach Wilson is no he's
quarterback jets
that was our trivia moment of the day
Zach Wilson Zach Wilson's dating this
chick all throughout High School right
and he's he's a star quarterback and
[ __ ] like that so and she's like she's
like a a really attractive young lady
right and they all of a sudden break up
and then all of a sudden like via
Instagram you see she starts kicking it
with his like wide receiver buddy on the
team [ __ ] up right so then everyone's
like you're all you're a [ __ ] homie
betrayer and all this [ __ ] in her
comments every time she posts homie
hopper that's what it says homie hopper
you're like you're a homie hopper you're
a [ __ ] homie hopper and everything
that she posts she gets called a homie
hopper and then one day she finally
[ __ ] lets it slip she's like [ __ ]
that he was [ __ ] my mom's friend whoa
Zach Wilson was
[Music]
she's like my name's not gonna be
tainted he's a male he's a MILF Hunter
Guy Code I have to sit here and [ __ ]
like put it all in strings and walls
that's grounds for her I think that's I
think it's in her favor I think it is
her favorite yeah that's just a little
smaller home
probably I will oh I'm gonna go over
your comments right now you know what
violates Guy Code for me is when guys
gossip okay so we're kind of gossiping
so it's like I told you something secret
that's supposed to be between us and
then you went off and told everybody in
the world that's breaking guy code
that's Geico that's Geico violation oh
man come on man that makes sense you're
like being my aunt right now
with no presents yeah that's really what
has to do with your dick size am I right
out of a lot of like there's there's
very many nuances with whether or not
you're breaking it but two that I really
think are very strict is um
do not try to build rapport with another
guy's girl by talking [ __ ] on him oh
that's the word that's a big that's a
fact unless unless they're married and
then you're all good then you're like
yeah [ __ ] this guy right that sucks I
mean you know what I'm talking about
when you try to play you try to play
into their like hey like I'm just
looking out for you oh that guy I don't
know who he was with that guy's a cuck
for sure yeah it's like that snake [ __ ]
but it's not really because he's trying
to help her it's really because he's
trying to be the Savior yeah I have a
blanket party with that guy [ __ ]
throw blanket on him and you hit him
with a phone book
I should have a blanket party that
sounds like a fun time yeah the Yellow
Pages dude
yeah honey is the same thing would
probably apply for like ladies too it's
just shitty Behavior humans just
shouldn't do these things wait is there
are there like
is there a portal code there's no girl
code
[Music]
The Sisterhood of trailing pants
this girl called the opposite like when
I said at the beginning uh where with
Guy Code it's like even if
uh you know uh my homie is doing some
kind of shady and then the chick is my
homie too I don't say anything to the
chick is a girl called the exact
opposite everybody everything you have
to say something chick is doing
something conversating the guys my homie
so I have to tell the guy that the chick
is being like breaking that uh
I don't want to say breaking that girl
code but you know what I mean if I'm a
chick and then my chick homie is doing
something Shady too and then she's got a
man but Batman is also kind of a friend
I go to the man I'm like hey you this
chick's acting up is that like Girl Code
I would debate how
I want to get involved
so it's gray area that's what girl code
is great area it's circumstantial not
accessory a lot of sorcery there it is I
I ended a friendship over guy code
violations well it was really just like
how many how many new violations were
there it was like 21. oh [ __ ] no I was I
was in a situation I think I talked
about this before but my buddy was like
cheating on his wife like hardcore like
in my in my roommate's room like yeah my
apartment well that's deep and I didn't
know I thought he just [ __ ] around
because he's always like do bits about
how hard he's cheating on his wife and
he would do it in front of her and she's
like laughing and [ __ ] and then one day
he's like yeah I'm gonna invite a check
over and like Yeah from Craigslist and
I'm like I'm like really I'm serious
dude he did that and then he had been
communicating with her on email but
that's how he found hers on Craigslist
oh my God so then I didn't know you
could hook up like that then I'm like
just for the like kecks and [ __ ] for the
lulls I'm like well this is kind of fun
like I don't think this is really
happening so then he actually has a will
come over and then he's like right under
the next room and I'm like holy [ __ ]
this is actually happening and I was
friends with both of them because I
actually met her doing something that I
probably shouldn't say because it'll
really identify things but I met her I
met her first and then I met him so like
I felt like like but we're not really
friends because she was married to him
so it wasn't like you know
it's like we're cool though it's like
we're friends or whatever because I'm
friends with both of you in your
marriage right and then after that I was
like I can't [ __ ] look at her in the
eye like I was like I can't be around
that's the other thing too like if
something like that happens your guy
code's so strong so you're like I'm not
gonna tell them but with my eyes you're
gonna know that
fade to black dude I'm done I'm out
piecing later that's that same example
that I gave you guys like a few months
back where I when I broke I code was
because a girl Bartered Girl Code
against mine
she goes I know something your girl did
but you got to tell me something my dude
did
you told me that that's crazy yeah
that's a fair exchange but I regret it I
think I made the wrong decision I should
have just said [ __ ] it and I should have
said hey if you know something I should
just break up with her because it must
be bad right I don't even know what it
is I should have just like silently took
action but instead I fell for it and I
was like all right let's hear it and she
gave me that thing and it was merited to
be like okay my relationship's over but
and then she was like can you just give
me anything she's like I know you know
something and I sold him the hell out
that's the offer you can't refuse but is
it really guy code if you guys aren't
truly friends he was he was my best
friend at the time okay never mind
you'll sell out your best friend like
that
you were put on Leverage though you know
what I'm saying that was like that's
like holding uh information Ransom yeah
it is yeah you should be in a position
if you're really good friends with this
person to to have a conversation with
him about the things that he's doing
that is just terrible hell yeah I'll
[ __ ] be the first one to call and say
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you son of a
[ __ ] it's like looking the other way
because it's just Guy Code you should
have that conversation with that person
I think that's what complicates guy code
is when you have a guy within that code
that's it's making it really tough like
he wasn't just like a he was serially
cheating like it was it was really bad
it would have caught up to him
eventually and it and it you know it did
in other ways later she already knew
anyway but it's like some guy codes are
really hard to keep for that reason like
like with with that you know like it's
happening in front of you you're now
like an accomplished yeah exactly it
kind of affects your conduct as a person
so you ever come from I'm like you're
[ __ ] making me accessory to cheating
yeah and I didn't get my dick wet how's
Donnie Brosco dude I was too far in I
didn't even get I didn't get to come and
I'm guilty [ __ ]